hi reject nation happy Monday kicking
off the week with wreck-it Ralph to
another trailer people John still hasn't
seen record Ralph but you know what it's
been a few years so maybe this should
entice people to go watch the first one
damn excuse made for John being here
right now thanks man no problem I got
your back hump me pasted on the day
shout-out for Rosa Parra but she wants
us to actually give a shout-out to a
person named Tony lura Tony Lara is
actually a really close friend of roses
daughter Cassandra there's a lot of buzz
at the end of the names here Tony is a
huge fan of the real rejects apparently
he heard about how we shout out rose
alot and Cassandra so he got really
excited and he wanted us to give him a
shout out Tony just wanted to say keep
spreading the word about the reject
nation to all the elementary school kids
that you know because there are target
market clearly and that's why we're
shouting you out today maybe you don't
even know what the words target market
mean yeah tell your teachers about us
yeah they're also the target market
let's do it people let's break the
Internet
[Music]
hey kiss so great
well product placement is over
[Music]
welcome to the search bar you do people
assume all your problems got solved
because a big strong man showed up
[Music]
shouldn't be Ralph Rex the Internet yes
and he is wreck-it Ralph
yeah but break the internet just
wrecking it kind of sounds better damn I
know right yeah it's cool huh like an IP
properties sandwich that's crazy I heard
they were gonna like feature the
princesses and stuff now I think they
got the actual voice talents of the
people who played these princesses back
to surprise it doesn't look like Disney
down crossover of these princesses they
like the directly from their animated
movies oh yeah
which is so cool better than you know
like a Pocahontas or something which was
hand-drawn well it's kind of see them
translated though yeah and an animated
version I don't know if there was like
some computer animated show of like
Pocahontas Pokemon the video like that
yeah and then like them making fun the
jokes of like what it means to be a
princess yeah movies is kind of cool for
Disney to be making fun of their own
brand in that way like they've gotten
better at that in their last few movies
like this especially stuff like like
tangled and things yeah and even frozen
a bit becoming more self-aware of their
formula and then pointing it out and
stuff I feel like a lot of people are
gonna tune in for that section right
there
not just the princess part but the whole
Disney section because she goes to like
oh my Disney or whatever it says there
you could even see in the shot you got
you're there you got the Star Wars you
got The Muppet Show in the background it
says Marvel Pixar got everything from
there well they even got the like that
they got the hat from the animation
building yeah you got the stormtroopers
chasing after her you got so much
craziness going on in this trailer it's
called the Internet so you're gonna want
to explore more than just the Disney
side of them crossing over to all the
whole Disney Universe yeah I'm gonna go
to Amazon I'll admit I am part of the
group that don't see vanellope and
Ralph's mix it up a lot with the crazy
Disney verse here that just seems like a
total blast to do yeah actually since
Disney owns so much right now yeah yeah
I guess that's a happy byproduct of this
cuz half of me kind of cringes at just
how much property is in this trailer but
at the same time I mean it is the
everything lives yeah to see Disney
mishmash their own properties is a
pretty cool idea - yeah exactly the
Internet is unlimited yeah what you can
do I can't help but wonder but someone's
gonna explore the Internet there's so
many dark paths you can tell it's even
gonna Teeter at all and hint at all of
like yeah you know what I mean of the
sites that kids should not be going to
yeah couple Joe parents but I don't
think anything - we're not gonna see
wreck-it Ralph find the dark web yeah
there might be some type of joke set up
at first them somewhat age-restricted
sight blocker going on at the beginning
it's the internet and we all know what
most people use it's gonna be the first
already wondering though what the actual
plot of this movie is the first movie
had a really clear defined plot and it
was a great excuse for Ralph to jump in
and out of all these other video games
in the arcade world we're here we're
just getting a lot of the references and
an internet references like Amazon and
snapchat we're getting all these wonder
over the setting but yeah I really get
what the directions gonna be yeah why
they're going into the Internet what the
main plot is at hand but in terms of
like the fun references and all that
that seems to be very present right now
and I'm loving it was actually kind of
freaking out a little bit when I was
seeing the Disney Princesses and all
that because I'm like whoa they're
really doing this
yeah all right guys well are you excited
for wreck-it Ralph - do you think it'll
be better than the first record Ralph
leave your comments down below people
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bail
because subscribe buttons don't really
work and you can check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
Tony lura Tony love you buddy